There's been a lot of talk I've seen of a four day work week.
That seems to be something that, that, uh, you've been focusing a lot on lately.
I'll tell you from my experience, when I was working a desk job and Israel,
I worked a normal office job five days a week,
the whole nine to five 96. And I was that whole time. I was like, dude, I could,
I could do this in four days easily. I mean.
You waste so.
Much time.
And I always thought that that idea was brilliant because it's got to
do a wonders for morale, right? I mean,
have you been reading studies and literature about that?
Yeah. The data is tremendous around a four day work week.
And it's also common sense because work kind of expands to fit into
whatever time you have. You know what I mean?
Like it might give you a bunch of stuff to do with me and I,
you've got five days. It's going to take you five days. Right?
If I say you got this much to do you have four days, four days with.
The promise of an extra, you know, week.
It's motivating, you know, in Israel,
we only have one day we can. So, you know,
it's funny when I moved here, I was like, this is like a dream.
I love the long weekend, but, um, I started to feel like, God,
I wish I had one more day. And then I started to feel guilty about that.
And like, I really can't get enough. Can I like.
Wait, wait, tell me more. So Israel, like, uh,
this is a one day weekend, which I'm guessing is Saturday.
Yeah. So, um, Sunday is the first day of the week. It's not Monday.
So.
That is wild. How that,
like I consider myself a fairly worldly cosmopolitan
person. And I did not know that.
Um, school is Sunday through Friday and you only have Saturday off.
They go to school six days a week. Can you imagine that? Hell? Yeah.
All right. I'm going to say something please. No, judge me. Um,
I went to a prep school that had classes on Saturday. So I actually have,
you can imagine that whole week.
And so I can't imagine it and it was not pretty.
Yeah.
I, I just read about it only recently because you've been talking about it and I
find the whole idea so interesting.
And I think I want to read more about it and learn what it really means.
Cause we actually have an, a business and we have maybe 20 employees,
so we could decide to go that route for everyone.
But I would have to know like what exactly it would mean.
Yeah. You should look into it for sure.
And then maybe even run like a trial in your case, you would run a trial,
but the data is very positive where it says that productivity, uh,
either stays the same or goes up. And the sense,
like you get the same amount of work done. Uh,
and then there are reduced stress levels, increased morale.
Like the people use that extra day off, uh,
in a way that they find restorative and, uh,
productive and like, uh, you know, personal way. Um,
and so it's me, it's like upside on the personal side and the,
on the business side of the productivity side, uh, there's really no loss.
And in some cases they're there, there are positives, right? So, uh,
and to me,
society-wide to America in particular and you guys have like a very distinct,
uh, job, if I do say so, but,
but like America generally has this, uh,
this workaholism problem or some,
one person called a work ism, which is probably like maybe a better name,
um, where Kane's projected decades ago. He said,
we'll be down to a 15 hour work week because we'll be so rich. Uh,
and it turns out his estimates of the top line were right.
Like we are as rich as he said we were going to be. Um, but our work,
we are actually migrating longer,
not shorter because of the nature of corporate culture and the economy
where it's like,
you have to be always on and available and the word is kind of creeps.
Uh, and that is what's happening right now.
And it's driving health problems, stress problems,
relationship problems, you know, like they're, uh,
a lot of signs already that the American work culture has kind of morphed into
something, uh, not terribly healthy.
And so I think a four day work week would be a massive improvement for many,
many corporate cultures. And I got to say like a lot of the times you're,
you're there. Like you're not doing. No. Like probably like one day a week.
You're just like, I didn't do today.
Yeah. I mean, I was, I probably was spending 30 hours a week on Reddit.
I've I've,
I've gone to pages of Reddit that men have never even known.
I've been to thousands of pages back unknown pages of Reddit.
That was my job.
Yeah. You're like someday I'm going to be a massive internet creator.
And I'm going to spend my time mining, like the deepest depths of the internet.
It preparation.
Yeah. It was crap. You know, in Finland, in Finland,
the prime minister had called for employers to allow employees to work not
only four days, but six hours a day.
So they are taking it to the next level.
That's some next level stuff.
I might not go to that extreme, but, uh, but I like where their heads are.
Right. What else? Not work. Yeah. In Finland, they're saying no work,
but you know, uh, I'll tell you what, because as business owners,
we're always thinking about like morale and you want to retain the good and you
want to retain the talent and make sure that they're happy and satisfied working
there. So I'll tell you what, on a four day work week,
I don't think anyone's going to leave your company. You know what I mean?
Yeah. I mean, it sounds exciting.
Well, and retention would be very, very high. I'm sure your,
your staff that are listening to this are like suddenly nodding being like, yes,
I don't know that I can do that for you Dan, because we have a production scale.
What can I do? I can't give you the, you know what I'm saying? I mean,
I'm sorry.
I used to work in movies. This is, this is easy by comparison.
If you don't work with like 14 hours, days regularly.
And this is as someone because I've also run startups.
And most of the startups I ran, uh, we worked our asses off,
you know what I mean? So like, so there, there isn't like, uh,
there, there, isn't some kind of something against hard work. I mean, I,
I love working hard. Uh, you know,
that was one of the funny things about running for president on universal basic
income where people are like, well, what about work? And then like,
depending upon my mood, I would respond to different ways.
But sometimes I'd be glib and be like, I'm Asian. I love work.
But then, you know, back off a little bit. But, but that,
that is one of the.
The fallacies right about the UBI people say, Oh, you're just not going to work.
But I feel like that's such a misunderstanding of the human condition. I mean,
nobody just wants to have no purpose in life. I mean, that's,
that's outrageous.
Well, this is the thing that, that like, you know, like make,
makes you laugh is like, they'll say two things. Simultaneously.
One work is the most important element of human life. And without it,
we are lost in two, no one will want to do it.
If you give them a little bit of money,
but those two things don't really come together. It's like, if it's so crucial,
then wouldn't we do it. And maybe slightly Bradley.
That's a great point.
Also the beautiful thing about UBI is that it goes to everyone at
any different position that they are in life.
So you could be having a crisis.
You could be having a meltdown mental thing that doesn't allow you to work right
now. You know,
you could be having a physical injury that you can't work right now,
even if you want to.
So it reaches everyone at different places in their life.
You know, like it's, it's finding that.
You're just thinking about this one situation where you're healthy and you do
want to work, but like, you're not going to work because you have money.
Because you're getting it. Yeah. What if you have an ailing loved one?
What if you have a young child or something or mental health care for your
sorrow or more.
Right now we have this incredible, the, well, we have a yeah.
Or a year in a pandemic. We have this homeless problem, homelessness problem.
That's just kind of crushing LA right now.
And if you gave each homeless person a,
if there was that bottom S you know, social safety net,
I think you would see a lot, lot less,
almost probably to zero in terms of homelessness, you know?
Yeah. If you had that level of resources, you could reduce homelessness very,
very dramatically. Uh,
the issue would be the transition because some of the people that are homeless
right now are, have mental health problems or drug addiction problems. And then,
and,
and don't may not even have a bank account where it's trying to send you the
money, like what what's going on. But over time,
if you knew that everyone had this money, that they were entitled to,
then you would reduce homelessness pretty quickly,
because then it would just look around and be like, wait a minute.
What's going on?
This person has got like thousands of dollars a year in value. Like,
you know, as if we can, um,
make sure that it's actually working for them in a way. And,
and to the extent that people aren't in a position where it would work for them
because of their own volition,
like it'd actually be pretty straightforward to like,
help it work for them where you'd have like an organization being like every
homeless person. I like bring it to the shelter.
Like we're gonna get thousands of dollars. Like, let's go get that done.
I mean, it's, it is funny how, uh, market driven,
everything is in the U S but if you give everyone intrinsic value and then all
of a sudden, like the market value starts kicking in for people. Well,
this is what I was running on before was that I knew that we'd been conditioned
to think that we all needed to be economically productive. And then I said,
you know what?
Technology is going to surpass our productivity in a lot of these arenas
pretty quick. And if we don't start evaluating ourselves in a different way,
then it's going to lead to disaster. And now we're seeing some version of it,
um, with the pandemic. Uh,
and so I think universal basic income would very quickly disentangle, uh,
this confused the, the,
the mixing of economic value and human value.
Because if you all just start getting money for breeding,
for living for existing, then you can start to feel like, okay,
we all have some worth, that's independent of, uh,
how much money I'm making at any moment in time. Uh,
and then that alone would humanize your perspective really quickly.
You know,
the other kind of nice thing I like about the four-day week is something I
always thought about when I was working in my, my desk job.
It's like,
you pointed out this kind of a workaholic. I think it's kind of in Israel,
it's the same, you know, and a lot of developed countries are around the world.
I think people just have this, um,
overwhelming of pressure,
social pressure to show how much they care about their job by
working unreasonable hours. You know, it's like,
and in Europe I was always blown away by the fact that people get
like an entire month off, you know, and there just freaking everyone disappears.
I mean, that, that to me is, is unfathomable that, uh,
and then the thing that blew my mind is when you learn that like Chinese year,
even in China, these people are,
people are getting a month off and you don't see that are two months off,
even a month off in America.
We don't have that little less than a month. We don't have that.
Did they travel back to their hometowns? In many cases,
I think it's less than a month, but it's significant. Yeah.
Though their work week, I think is like the Israeli model of six days.
Really well. So they work hard. But the thing is in Israel too,
you don't have that. Well, you get holidays, but not like a designated time off.
And so to me, it's like, we, we,
as human beings need to be defined by more than just our jobs.
Now,
I think a four day work week would be a massive value out of the United States.
But I think that, you know,
you wouldn't make it a one size fits all for every organization because I've
been parts of some organizations where you probably want to have a, you know,
like, uh, a longer work schedule.
And there are certain types of roles and, um, the where it makes sense.
But I think as a default setting where like the expectation is you have a four
day work week,
I think it would be an incredible improvement in large part because of what you
just said, Ethan, which is like, what is the purpose of life? Is it our job?
Or is it something bigger? Uh,
that integrates a job includes a job,
but it's not like exclusively a job. So,
uh, the four-day work week is something that to me would actually
make work like an appropriate part of our law.
Um, you know, uh,
in a way that right now we have to be honest that it's just creeping
upwards. Like it's,
it's going like from five plus into like that
zone. Uh, and I'm a data guy and there are very,
very clear signs that right now it's having a damaging effect on
our health, mental health, stress levels, relationships, family formation, um,
and all of that stuff was pre pandemic. Um,
the post in the pandemic, uh,
we just have to do anything we can to give people like a,
a real sense of wellbeing and even folks who
are doing well, quote unquote,
like relatively speaking during this time are not exactly like
necessarily mentally doing well. You know, there's just a lot of,
uh, there's a lot of stress right now, um,
that I think if you had a couple of days a week or three days a week where you
were genuinely disengaged from work,
it would be enormously helpful for so many of us. Do.
You see yourself doing that?
You know, it's funny, it's like,
it certainly sounded like I was talking about myself. Does that, um, I mean,
for me, I'm in a similar boat to you. I think where, you know,
we're in a situation where we're just trying to do things and help people.
Like I'm very busy right now. Uh, you know,
I just spoke at the DNC last night and then I went and talked about my speaking
at the DNC late later in the night. So,
uh, uh, you know, we were distributing economic relief.
Like you were working on this data project where we're trying to get people paid
for their data. Um,
I'm helping these down-ballot candidates who are running on universal basic
income. Cause we gotta try and make it happen for folks,
some campaigning for them all the time, uh, um,
campaigning for Joe in common against Trump. So I'm busier than ever.
And it's cool in the sense that like the world was on fire and,
uh, I feel like, uh, thanks to you and thanks to, you know,
some other folks who believed in me, like,
I feel like I've got something of a fire extinguisher fire,
and I got a fire extinguisher. Right. Um,
so like I better try and put the fire out because you know,
it's like not everyone has a fire extinguisher. Um, it's just like you guys,
where you looked up to, you were like, wow, there's a lot of freaking, uh,
need and suffering right now. And like, I can help. So you tried to help,
like I'm in the same boat you are where th th this is a time for me to like,
not worry too much about, you know, like, you know, my, my own, uh,
like balance.
Yeah. I mean, it's,
I think it's different for entrepreneurs are people who manage. I mean,
obviously it's important,
but for people who don't have much of a choice in the matter, you know,
we're expected to do things.
For listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new one.
Yeah.